[Musique]
cet endroit avec une maison de fou il
vaut mieux entendre ça quelque chose
[Musique]
ce qui est de toi quand tu fais le point
sur ta vie de quoi est-ce que tu es
fière il n'a jamais le moindre sous en
poche tu le sais bien un jour tu vas te
réveiller mais il sera trop tard et tu
auras plus de tes yeux pour pleurer
est-ce que tu as déjà eu des troubles de
l'anxiété et ben maintenant j'en ai à
cause de
temps seulement de se préoccupe vraiment
de leur avenir ils vont faire quoi une
fois dehors tant qu'à faire autant jouer
gros
ça va être le plus grand comme battre de
l'histoire
il y a encore de l'espoir
reviens ici file-moi une chips
je t'aime mon pote pour
[Musique]